hey guys welcome back the new rockstars
I'm your host Sam bash and today we're
talking about ready player one the film
adaptation of the hit novel of the same
name written by Ernest Cline I don't
need to really go too far into that
because that's not what you guys care
about today I'm not caring about the
plot or spoilers to the pot or whatever
you just want to know about every single
reference Easter Egg every little hint
that's hiding in this trailer if you
didn't already know there's a butt ton
of Easter eggs in this trailer so let's
get going as always here's your spoiler
warning for ready player one the novel
the movie the fan fiction and so on also
Eric Boston and also breakdown of the
comic-con trailer a while back so go
ahead and click down on the the channel
button and go watch that but enough of
that let's get going my name is Wade
watts my dad picked that name because it
sounded like a superhero's alter-ego but
he died when I was a kid my mom -
there's nowhere left to go except the
Oasis
[Music]
right off the bat even before we get
into the Oasis we can see one character
from the mad walls two years of Toei
specifically ret though on the side of
that mobile home but also pay very close
attention just to the right is a very
small sticker of the Pixar legend Mike
Wazowski at least it looks like him I
don't know if they have the rights to
use Disney characters because I
green-skinned he's got horns he's got a
single eye scooting forward to the scene
with our main character Wade Watts
entering the Oasis if you pay close
attention to his eye where as he puts it
on you'll notice some customization it
was pretty quick but you can definitely
tell that there is a Batman logo right
there smacked on the side but now let's
scoot forward to New York City inside
the Oasis being rearranged rebuilding
itself in that whole creation of the
bridge because I'm feeling like this is
the beginning of the race scene if not
this might just be the initial reboot of
the system as soon as someone joins the
Oasis after being away for a little bit
but I'm pretty sure this is right before
the big race I'm very excited for that
race
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
alright guys next up is the introduction
of Wade's avatar parsable which is a
play on Percival one of the Knights of
King Arthur's Court in the Oasis we see
a bunch of awesome vehicles entered in
the New York race which looks to be for
the copper key which you can see on the
banner right up there one of the keys
that could be part of finding the Easter
egg in the film but also let's point out
all the famous cars and Easter eggs in
this scene in the upper left hand corner
you'll notice the a-team van then down
below you see speed racers Mach 5 very
cool also the Batmobile from the
original Adam West Batman series my
personal favorite also the Interceptor
from Mad Max the road warrior and on top
of that we also get that super Jack dude
which you guys all know as Ryu from
Street Fighter Ryu hey we're just gonna
calm where everyone he's just world big
on get my hug he's not the only Street
Fighter character in this trailer don't
worry we'll talk about all of them very
soon we then see parsable waves avatar
and Trinity Back to the Future DeLorean
of course is very popular in this
trailer which we've seen before in the
first trailer as well but you should pay
attention to his little belt buckle why
because that's a Thundercats logo on
there so cool Thundercats
scoot your forward a little bit to the
DeLorean racing down the track notice
the grille of the car that red bar is a
throwback to the book in which Wade's
car is a mixed bag of movie and TV
references just jammed together this one
being the red bar from KITT in Knight
Rider the TV series haha
very cool next clip they stay because of
all the things they can be can you feel
this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything alright now we get the
party scene that we saw in the first
trailer which I'm a big fan of there's
so many characters just jammed in here
like Slade Wilson aka Deathstroke
passing Wade as he's entering the club
and a new female avatar that's not
Harley Quinn I wonder who that could be
would you see another familiar video
game hero right after that notice this
character right behind Artemis looks an
awful lot like Lara Croft ah there she
is in our blue tank top and everything
we actually see her again as she
approaches the bar and hold on a second
a lot of references right here for
starters the Hat the bartender is
wearing is clearly that worn by the band
Devo you probably know what that band is
right probably not so then we get blanca
from street fighter also someone who
looks a lot like Commander Shepard from
Mass Effect but his back is to us a
little bit and then quite possibly
professor pig or at least his mask on
one of the characters directly behind
Artemis big villain from Batman lore one
of my personal favorites oh boy we're
just getting start with these references
and it's good for just a little bit we
see the flying dancing once again with
Gandalf right there in the bottom
twirling around having a great old time
good for him her next clip please the
Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead I created a hidden object an easter
egg
first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars okay Wow
Wade gives us all this exposition for
the movie check out this retro Nintendo
peripheral in the corner that's a
classic NES zapper boys and girls right
there on the wall of his van what a
fanboy wonder if that even works with
his headset probably not probably don't
do anything and scoot afford a little
bit more to James holidays video noticed
his pins on his lapel one is very
clearly a Simon Says logo which is
pretty fun when the original games but
also notice the one kind of hidden at
the very top it looks an awful lot like
a d20 which makes a lot of sense for his
character an ultra nerd like himself
would definitely be in 2d and be moving
forward once again to the literal Easter
Egg clip pay attention because there are
a few goodies here right off the bat the
dragon's garden the eggs look just like
this looking off a lot like the Dragons
from The Mortal Kombat logo and the
statues around the Easter egg look a lot
like Mortal Kombat characters now it is
a little dark and a little hard to tell
but it kind of looks like to the right
you can see Raiden in the top right
little nook and right below him you can
see sub-zero doing a little pose
possibly pretty sure the characters on
the other side are also Mortal Kombat
characters but you guys let me know who
they are in the comments down below also
if you're wondering what that symbol is
on the ceiling that a looking thing it's
actually a symbol for an ox Almanac from
the ready player one series also if you
guys remember that's the logo on the key
found in that final shot of the last
trailer the comic-con exclusive very
cool next clip of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him
here we see the bike from Akira once
again one of my favorite fictional
vehicles but don't let it scoop by it
too fast because there are some goodies
hidden on it yes on it notice the
stickers right there on the front on the
top of the bike we gives you the classic
Wonder Woman logo as well as the logo
for Greatest American Hero that's a very
deep cut that's a weird reference but
glad it's there you also see the logo
for tato the Japanese video game company
who made little games such as space
invaders Bubble Bobble you know the
classics I also if you just scoot down
just a little bit see right there my
girl my friend Miss pac-man
shadow I'm so glad you're in this movie
next noticed this monster truck right
here underneath Artemis as she's doing
her sick jump in the Akita bike this is
actually not to the original monster
truck bigfoot yeah the original author
chuck that's just for me i guess i'm
really excited about that but also don't
miss this other little easter egg right
behind the monster truck the billboard
hmm does that say that's right it's an
ad for delta city the future has a
silver lining very catchy and pretty fun
since this is a nod to Robocop Delta
City is the rebranded name of old
Detroit and this is the same ad from
that series moving along I'm gonna just
call him Wade's avatar cuz it saved me
from having to say pars of what I'm not
gonna I'm messing it up so I'm just
gonna say Wade's avatar you see him
accepting a key from a wise looking
wizard who's spoiler warning is anorak
the name we talked about earlier this is
also sort of the ghost of halliday
within the game the creator of the Oasis
is pretty fun but don't get confused cuz
this next scene when you see the
projection of the key in Wade's headset
looks to be the copper key which is from
the race earlier not the key that he's
getting from an Iraq that looks to be
the crystal key hmm from the first
trailer also fun little detail look at
Wade's avatar suit right here it looks
to be the suit from buckaroo banzai his
adventures across the 8th dimension
exhale weird movie I watched as a child
and gave me many nightmares but I'm a
fan of it next clip please - life and
death stuff the Oasis
world's most important economic resource
there's nothing less than a war for
control of the future all right now
moving forward to this alleyway scene
notice the sticker on the back of this
truck right here looks an awful lot like
the Tomb of Horrors logo from Dungeons &
Dragons
Tomb of Horrors there's actually not too
many Easter eggs in this clip but I do
love that logo now on to the big bad
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came here to escape ma'am right
at the opening we get freakin King Kong
jumping off the Empire State Building
with biplanes circling him fun
recreation of the classic scene from the
original film also fan Theory it would
be pretty fun for Warner Brothers to
gift us a King Kong vs. Godzilla fight
in this movie a few years before their
actual big screen fight coming out
Godzilla versus King Kong it's gonna be
exciting but hey maybe I'm getting ahead
of myself
next we see the epic army charging
towards a panel there are so many
characters here just so many itsy-bitsy
little characters they've been animated
they just shoved into one scene but
here's a few that we can definitely
point out starting from the left we can
see l-drago and from battle born is also
a bunch of the battletoads leading the
charge and one of the knights from the
atari game jaws writing his trademark
ostrich also there's some speculation of
this turtle over here if you focus right
there a lot of people are saying that
he's one of the ninja turtles but he
doesn't quite look right so I'm thinking
this could be slash in his new
redesigned look from the TMNT comics
also the next sweeping shot of the
battle in the bottom right corner we get
another glimpse of a battle born
character this time Toby if you pay
attention you can see his combat suit
for a second or two also this is worth
pointing out but the boom box that
weight is holding it does look a lot
like the boom box from say anything but
it's actually a different model this one
is from sharp but the original was a
Toshiba model now that was the first
nerdy thing I think I've said in this
entire video and then a few quicky
catches the dance floor we see floating
in the dance hall looks to be a
recreation of the dance floor from
Saturday Night Fever you notice the
square designs of both of them and of
course you guys caught this one but it's
worth mentioning we see Harley and Joker
dancing together looking in our in fear
it's something happening above them but
it's also worth mentioning I think
Harley's in her Arkham game getup
also the Hat the Joker is wearing looks
an awful lot like The Killing Joke hat
but that one might be a stretch but hey
who knows next clip
[Music]
something much bigger than just myself
are you willing to fight help us save
the Oasis
who so many nerds me very happy about
this clip let's point out all of our
favorite characters leading the charge
we see tracer from overwatch chun-li
from Street Fighter Cassie cage in the
back from Mortal Kombat once again our
friend Laura Croft Leia Croft Laura
Kraft mmm ale Croft right behind her and
to the right some of my favorite bad
guys from any film army of Darkness the
Deadites also the rabbit was a tricky
one for me to identify but I'm thinking
this is the main character from the game
of loup-garou next we see Wade's avatar
shooting a double barreled shotgun out
of his car which looks an awful lot like
the same one from Mad Max but modified
with a little scope on it cuz why not
it's a video game but also don't put a
scope on a shotgun kids that was don't
want put your face right there it's
gonna hurt it's gonna for just a little
bit to this notebook in the real world
that Wade has there's a list of
references on it that I'll leave to you
guys to interpret going down the list I
caught glimpses of gremlins Dark Crystal
the Temple of Doom crow splash helms
deep
HBO swims on some and then Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy the very bottom what
this all means I'm not sure but if we
get a glaive from Kroll in this movie
I'll be very happy it'll be very violent
but it'll be very cool next we get this
room with floating cassettes or DVD
cases which it's kind of hard to make
out what is up there but I was able to
notice the Batman film Full Metal Jacket
Scarface airplane back to the future and
possibly Breakfast Club but there are a
couple repeats up there and some of them
are just too small to read no matter how
much I changed them our next shot worth
looking at has weights avatar holding
the boombox on the ridge of a mountain
surrounded by some characters most
notably though Deadshot from DC Comics
and Suicide Squad as well as behind him
we get another Street Fighter character
saket we then get an awesome shot of a
Gundam specifically the Gundam rx-78 to
suit which just made me giddy to see on
the big screen I'm very excited for that
we also got an awesome shot of Chucky
himself taking out an enemy and finally
the Iron Giant to close out the trailer
I'm gonna be honest I teared up
I teared up when I saw him in the first
trailer so I cannot wait to see them in
this movie for those of you were
wondering that last music cue we heard
in this trailer is actually a clip from
the Back to the Future movie could this
be hinting to more Back to the Future
references in this film possibly but
that's it from me I hope you guys
enjoyed all my easter eggs I was able to
find if I missed any
maybe let me know in the comments down
below or on Twitter at Sam bash be sure
to LIKE this video share it with your
friends and subscribe to new rock source
for more breakdown there's a bunch of
really fun ones I think you'll enjoy for
flash Game of Thrones I also check out
the show need to know it's a very fun
talk show that I'm a part of with all
the fun people here again my name is Sam
and I'll see you guys next time